GREG: HAPPY INDEPENDENCE DAY
EVERYONE.
INDEPENDENCE, FREEDOM MEANS A
LOT MORE THESE THESE DAYS
DOESN’T IT?
TODAY WE HAVE HAD HER FREEDOM
TESTED IS LIKE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
GREG YOU LOOK JUST OKAY IN A
SPEED.
I LOOK AMAZING THANK YOU BUT THE
WORLD SURE TOOK A STRANGE TURN
THINGS TO THE REAL THREAT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE DISTURBING
REBRANDING OF PROTESTS GREATLY
LOST THE FREEDOM TO GO TO WORK
AND EARN A LIVING, THE FREEDOM
TO GO OUT AND SOCIALIZE, GET A
HAIRCUT, HUG GRANDMA, HUG
GRANDMA WHILE GIVING HER A
HAIRCUT AND OF COURSE THE
FREEDOM TO RUN A SMALL BUSINESS
WITHOUT SOME D TAG SETTING FIRE
TO IT IN THE NAME OF JUSTICE.
LET’S FACE IT THE FIRST HALF OF
2020th IN A FLAMING PILE OF
GARBAGE.
YOU EXPECT THE NEW YEAR TO BE
FRESH AND HOPEFUL AND EXCITING?
IS LIKE A BLIND DATE.
WE HOPED 2020 WAS GOING TO BE IN
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE DOOR
LOOKING LIKE THIS ELVIS AND
INSTEAD WE GOT THIS ELVIS.
BUT IF 2020s WERE A BANDIT
WOULD BE MAROON 5.
OF 2020 WERE AT TV SHOW WOULD BE
"THE VIEW" IN ITS 2020 WERE
HUMAN IT WOULD BE THIS.
WE HAD NO IDEA HOW MUCH CRAZY WE
WERE IN FOR.
EVERY WEEK THINGS GOT WEIRDER
AND SCARIER AND JUST WHEN YOU
THOUGHT IT COULDN’T GET MORE
CHAOTIC THERE WAS STILL ROOM FOR
MORE CRAZINESS BUT YOU KNOW HOW
TV SHOWS DO PREDICTIONS AT THE
BEGINNING OF EVERY YEAR?
LET’S SEE HOW WE DID.
"FORTUNE" MAGAZINE WITH SAMPLEY
DEVOTES A "WHEEL OF FORTUNE"
TERRITORY.
THE AWESOME TASK OF MAKING
PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE AHEAD SOME
HIGHLIGHTS THEY EXPECT
TURBULENCE IN THE WORLD ECONOMY
BUT NOTHING LIKE 2083 QUINTIN
TARANTINO MAY WIN AN OSCAR AND
HE SHOULD.
>> I LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE
ASSUMING JEN WROTE ILLUMINED
DOOM.
>> HOW MANY MORE APPLE’S?
GREG: I REALLY DID LOSE A LOT OF
PLAY, LIKE CAP A PERSON.
THAT OFFERED ABSOLUTE NOTHING
FOR THIS PRESENT SHOW.
I GOT LISTENING TO IT AND THE
GUESTS WEREN’T EVEN CLOSE BUT
WHO COULD HAVE PREDICTED THE
STOP THAT WOULD REALLY HAPPEN?
WHO COULD HAVE REDACTED SCHOOLS
WOULD BE CLOSED AND YOU’D BE
STUCK INSIDE THE HOUSE WITH YOUR
KIDS ALL DAY AND WORKING FROM
HOME IF YOU ARE LUCKY THAT BUT
NO PRO-SPORTS TO WATCH.
ALSO SOCCER, AND YOU CAN’T GO TO
THE JIM COINING MORE.
I WENT BACK TO LIFT THINGS SOCKS
FILLED WITH SAND.
IF TYRUS HAD PREDICTED SOCIAL
DISTANCING WE’D BE LIKE WHAT HE
TALKING ABOUT?
IF WE PREDICTED A GLOBAL
SHORTAGE OF TOILET PAPER WHICH
LED TO VIDEOS LIKE THIS.
THE WORLD IS GOING TO.
NO ONE PREDICTED ANY OF THIS AND
SO MANY THINGS WOULD BE CANCELED
BASKETBALL BASEBALL HOCKEY
GRADUATION MOVIES STATUES COPS
ON TV AND COPS ON THE STREET.
THAT WAS THE NEXT WAVE OF CRAZY
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
DID ANYONE BE -- THINK WE’D BE
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
ESPECIALLY AFTER A BOLIVIAN
DESTRUCTION?
NOW THE OUTRAGES UNITED BY ONE
THEME COME DISCUSSION OVER THE
DIALOGUE IS REPLACED BY VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THE LIVES HAVE NO
REALISTIC DEMANDS.
TO FUNDING THE POLICE?
YOU ARE JUST ASKING FOR NO AND
IF YOU DO IT’S NEVER ENOUGH IS
IT?
YOU DEFEND LAWLESSNESS IS
PROTESTS AND WHEN THE RIDE GETS
TOO CLOSE TO THEIR HOME THEY
CALL THE COPS.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE A COMMUNITY
WITHOUT COPS WE JUST GOT A
GLIMPSE.
TAKE DEB AUTONOMOUS ZONE IN
SEATTLE WERE COPS WERE LOUD.
FIRST THEY CALLED IT THE CHAD
ANNOUNCED THE CHOP.
AND THE WAY THEY BUILT A WALL
THAT YOU WALK THE STREETS I’M
THE STREETS ON.
IN SHORT THEY BECAME BRIEFLY
REPUBLICAN.
ALL THEY NEEDED WERE GOLF CLUBS
EXCEPT THEY GET IT WRONG, ON
OTHER PEOPLES TURF.
A MOMENT YOU ALLOW TRESPASSING
UNDER THE GUISE OF A PROTEST
THAT GUARANTEES TROUBLE BECAUSE
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALLOWS THAT
AS IT HAS IT’S GOING TO PICK
CITIZENS VERSUS THE MOB.
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA WITH ANY
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THEY END UP
ENSURING IN A BOARD WE DIDN’T
SEE COMING.
ESPECIALLY THEY MOCK THE PUBLIC
FOR TRYING TO DEFEND ITSELF FROM
THE CRIMINALS.
POLICE ARE LAUGHING AT YOU AS
THEY PROTECT THEMSELVES.
I’M GLAD THE ZONE WAS TRIED SO
THE REST OF THE IDIOTS SEE HOW
SOCIETY WORKS WITHOUT POLICE.
IT DOESN’T AND WE STILL GOT THE
VIRUS AMONG US.
JUST WHEN SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY ARE STARTING TO OPEN UP
AGAIN OTHER PARTS OF THE
CLOSING.
OF EXPERIENCE LIFE WITHOUT OUR
FREEDOMS AND THAT.
WE WANT IT BACK THAT WITH
FREEDOM COMES RESPONSIBILITY, WE
KNOW THAT.
KEEP WASHING HER HANDS, WEAR A
MASK AND BE MINDFUL OF GRANDMA.
THAT WAY MAYBE WE CAN STOP THE
VIRUS BUT NOT THE CRAZINESS.
ON TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE IT’S
AN ELECTION YEAR.
THE GOOD NEWS, 2020 IS HALF
OVER.